mendelevium which is named after one of
the most important people as far as the
periodic table is concerned is Dmitri
Mendeleev mendelevium is named after
Mendeleev in Russia the periodic table
is called them Mendeleev table and you
can see here on my tie I've got a
picture of Mendeleev it's another
element which has absolutely zero use in
the real world he is one of the iconic
iconic pictures of chemists that most
chemists will recognize Mendeleev ah
Mendeleev is all to do with how it was
discovered to put the periodic table
together for a long time people knew
that there were different elements and
that they knew they had different
properties what they couldn't do was
rationalize those properties and
understand why certain elements behaved
in a similar manner even though in
principle they should have been very
different
but Mendeleev has another cause of fame
he is famous in Russia because he was
the person who worked out the standard
for the strength of vodka so here I have
a bottle of Russian Mendeleev you see
says mint Olivia and vodka with a
periodic table on it and here's the
formula ethanol plus water and Mendeleev
was the person that worked out the
standard of 40% of ethanol in waters
being vodka and in fact it's remarkable
the number of experiments you read where
people have used 40% ethanol in water as
the solvent for their reaction doubtless
because they had the Handy bottle of
vodka or some similar drink